there is an environmental mystery afoot
and it begins with the seemingly trivial
detail that reveals a disaster of global
proportions one day you notice that the
honey you slather on your morning toast
is more expensive instead of switching
to jam you investigate the reason for
the price hike what you find is shocking
the number of domesticated honeybees in
the US has been decreasing at an
alarming rate this decline appears too
big to be explained by the usual causes
of bee death alone disease parasites or
starvation the typical crime scene has
almost no adult bees left in the hive
except perhaps a lonely Queen and a few
other survivors
it's full of untouched food stores and a
brood of unborn larvae suggesting that
the adults vacated without waiting for
them to hatch but what's particularly
eerie is that there is no telltale mass
of dead or dying bees nearby either they
have forgotten their way back to the
hive or they have simply disappeared
these mysterious disappearances aren't
new humans have been collecting honey
for centuries but it wasn't until
European settlers in the 1600s
introduced the subspecies apis mellifera
that we domesticated bees since the 19th
century beekeepers have recorded
occasional mass disappearances giving
them enigmatic names like disappearing
disease spring dwindle disease and
autumn collapse but when in 2006 such
losses were found to affect more than
half of all hives in the US the
phenomenon got a new name colony
collapse disorder the most frightening
thing about this mystery isn't that
we'll have to go back to using regular
sugar in our tea
we farm bees for their honey but they
also pollinate our crops on an
industrial scale generating over a third
of America's food production this way
so how can we find the culprit behind
this calamity here are three of the
possible offenders
exhibit a pests and disease most
infamous is the varroa mite a miniscule
red pest that not only invades colonies
and feeds on bees but also transfers
pathogens that stunt bee growth and
shortens their lifespan Exhibit B
genetics the queen is the core of a
healthy hive but nowadays the millions
of Queen Bee is distributed in
commercial hives are bred from just a
few original Queens which raises the
worry about a lack of genetic diversity
which could weaken bees defenses against
pathogens and pests exhibit C chemicals
pesticides used both on commercial
beehives and agricultural crops to ward
off parasites could be getting into the
food and water the honeybees consume the
researchers have even found that some
pesticides damage the honeybees homing
abilities so we have a file full of
clues but no clear leads in reality
scientists the actual detectives on this
case face disagreement over what causes
colony collapse disorder for now we
assume that several factors are the
cause honeybees aren't necessarily in
danger of extinction but fewer bees
overall means less pollination and
higher food costs so it's crucial that
scientists solve the case of the
vanishing bees because while having less
honey might be a buzzkill crop shortages
are something that would truly stay
you